es ist insgesamt wirklich eine neue Welt
in der wir Deutschen gerade Aufwachen
wir hatten uns so verlassen auf die
regelbasierte Weltordnung und darauf für
immer von den USA beschützt zu werden
wofür wir Sie natürlich gleichzeitig
total verachten logisch und jetzt das
ein Krieg nach dem anderen wenn es blöd
läuft gilt bald nur noch das Recht der
stärkeren darauf sind wir nicht
vorbereitet trotz Zeitenwende apropos
wie geht's eigentlich der Zeitenwende so
geht so ja Zitat Scholz wir werden nun
Jahr für Jahr 2% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts für Verteidigung
ausgeben so letzten August wurde das mit
den 2% übrigens wieder rausgestrichen
aus dem Ampel Haushaltsgesetz
stattdessen heißt es da nun wir streben
2% im mehrjährigen Durchschnitt
an so wie ich es anstrebe mir ein
routergerät zu
kaufen und braucht die bundesweh
überhaupt so viel Geld es fehlt an
Unterkünften funktionierende Toiletten
saubere Duschen Spinde Hallen
Sportanlagen truppenküchen
Betreuungseinrichtung Munitionslager und
Waffenkammern und nicht zuletzt auch
WLAN WLAN na und früher haben wir auch
ohne WLAN Kriege verloren ohne Ende
fehlann laut Institut der deutschen
Wirtschaft liegt unsere
Unterfinanzierung gegenüber den
natostandards trotz Sondervermögen bei
mindestens
394 Milliarden Euro und spätest wenn
sleepy Joe Biden endgültig einschläft
oder Trump die Wahl gewinnt müssen wir
die versprochenen 2% e investieren ja im
letzten Jahr waren es übrigens nur
1,39% dieses Jahr werden es wohl 1,6%
müssten wir jetzt mal dringend als
Gesellschaft klären wollen wir uns
überhaupt selber verteidigen können wenn
nicht ist ja auch okay müss wir nur mal
aussprechen zur Not können wir ja immer
noch beim Nachbarn unter den atomschirm
schlüpfen ich wette der der freut sich
ja ich wette der freut sich so im
nächsten Jahr wird das 2% Ziel eventuell
erreicht aber nur mit Rechentricks um
nicht zu sagen mit Zaubertricks wirklich
z.B rechnet Lindner die Zinsen von
früheren Verteidigungsausgaben also für
die er ja Schulden gemacht hat einfach
mit ein ebenso Kindergeldzahlung an
Bundeswehrangehörige und ausdrücklich
kein Witz Versorgungsleistungen für
exangehörige der Nationalen Volksarmee
ja die NVA ist wieder Teil des deutschen
weretas da kann ja nichts mehr
schiefgehen Günther komm es geht wieder
los mach hinne das Land braucht
uns diesmal machen wir die Amis fertig
ich dachte es geht gen die Russen
was ja der späte Sieg des Sozialismus so
und
keiner niemand kann im Moment sagen wie
das wird wenn das Sondervermögen alle
ist schon ab 2027 entsteht dann ein
Finanzierungsloch von 40 Milliarden pro
Jahr jedenfalls wenn man 2% anstrebt
kurz gesagt die schieben das Problem
einfach auf die nächste Regierung denn
2027 ist die Ampel ja schon zwei Jahre
abgewählt wenn ich richtig gerechnet
habe so und vielleicht können wir auch
endlich mal anfangen dass viele klüger
auszugeben Prioritäten setzen und z.B
Munition kaufen wenn keine platzmunition
ja verfügbar war sind wir halt in den
verschiedenen Lagen auch gezwungen
gewesen einfach Peng zu rufen man
schreib halt dieses Peng und da fühlt
man sich dann wirklich wie der letzte
Vollidiot
zurecht man muss ja gar nicht immer Peng
rufen warum ruft man nicht mal
doppelwums
oder so eins der reichsten Länder der
Welt schafft es bis heute nicht seine
Soldaten mit ausreichend Munition zu
versorgen tatsächlich reicht die
Munition im Ernstfall nur für zwei Tage
ist kein Spaß demnächst in ihrem
Geschichtsbuch der 30stündige Krieg ja
für meh reicht's nicht noch mal wollen
wir eine funktionierende Bundeswehr oder
nicht falls ja müssen wir aufhören mit
albernen Rechentricks so verlogen wie es
im Moment läuft gibt's nämlich nur noch
einen Weg wie wir das 2% Ziel schaffen
das Verteidigungsministerium bittet um
ihre Hilfe Deutschland soll J des Jahr
2% des Bruttoinlandsprodukts für
Verteidigung ausgeben letztes Jahr lag
das BIP bei unfassbaren 3,87 Billionen
warum weil ihr deutschen so wahnsinnig
fleißig seid daher die Bitte hört
endlich auf so viel zu arbeiten je
niedriger das BIP desto weniger sind 2%.
echte Patrioten bleiben zu Hause und
chillen den ganzen Tag vor der Glotze
treffen sich mit den Kumpels in der
Fußgängerzone oder machen im falschesten
Moment Urlaub auf Malle und wenner fragt
hät den nicht auch wann anders machen
können sagst du nein nein
nein chill mal
[Musik]
deutschlandal das ist die letzte Chance
wahrscheinlich muss runter
immerinoriten ampelminister einige gute
Sachen eingeführt beim Bund z.B das neue
bundeswehrbeschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
absoluter Killer beim Scrabble Spiel ne
die Bundeswehr kauft mehr von der Stange
damit es endlich vorangeht mit der
Beschaffung sehr gut gibt schon erste
Erfolge seit dem Wochenende ist bekannt
dass Deutschland für 1,3 Milliarden Euro
digitale Funkgeräte gekauft hat ohne
dass geklärt ist wie sie eingebaut
werden können der Minister hat davon
offenbar erst aus den Medien erfahren B
einigermaßen verärgert ja das wäre ich
auch wie doof sind die denn und wieso
erfährt er das aus den Medien das daert
jetzt Jahre bis die Funken eingebaut
sind und kostet sicher zusätzliche
Milliarden wir lernen selbst ein
hemdsärmliger Reformer und Anpacker wie
Pistorius scheitert gelegentlich am
System die Bundeswehr muss dringend
digitalisiert werden und jetzt dieser
funkgerätegau zum Glück war ich civi im
Gegensatz zu dim
wischmeer dietm wischme Funker der
letzten Reserve
seinem allerlzten
Manöver ja Eichel her betw bitte kommen
betw bist du da hallo Schatz ich bin
didymaus ruf bitte mal eben in der
Kaserne an und sag denen dass wir
angegriffen werden und lass eine
Quittung geben für private
Auslagen ja sie lachen weil ich hier mit
meinem eigenen Handy sagen wir mal Funke
aber genau das ist bei uns längst Alltag
viele Soldaten tragen bei Übung wie
dieser ihre eigenen
Wintersachen ty ist privat das einzige
Funkgerät ist seit Monaten kaputt
natürlich alles Fratze ich bin mit dem
49 € Ticket ins Manöver gefahren und
wenn mein Sohn nicht an der Gesamtschule
wäre hätte ich nicht mal eine
funktionierende Knarre unsere einzige
Hoffnung ist dass Putins Truppe am
Leverkusener Kreuz im Berufsverkehr
stecken bleibt Baustellen gelten als
passive Bewaffnung und gehören damit zum
Verteidigungshaushalt die Funkgeräte
müssen jetzt in 200 verschiedene
Fahrzeugtypen eingebaut werden deren
Batterien aber zu schwach sind um sie zu
betreiben hätte man nicht vorher fragen
können ob die Teile auch reinpassen ich
wäre davon ausgegangen dass man s vor
der Bestellung aber das ist mit der
Bestellung darüber ged die Integration
Erfolg er geht davon aus dass ich einer
Gedanken macht daran merkt man er ist
noch nicht lange beim Bund kennt man ja
von ikeer du kaufst ja ein neues
billyreal hast aber keinen Bock vorher
nachzumessen ob das ins Zimmer passt
quetscht eine halbe Stunde dran rum und
schmeiß es am Ende wütten den Müll nur
dass dieser Billy halt Milliarden kostet
so und was machen wir jetzt Brieftauben
Rauchzeichen stille Post in der Not
griff man auf eine Lösung aus den
Anfängen der Bundeswehr zurück und
führte den kratmelder wieder ein das
neue Kat bei der bundesf das heißt ein
Soldat mit Motorrad als
nachrichtenkurier warum nicht bei
auslandseinsetzen dauert ein
Ferngespräch dann halt dre Wochen bis
der Mop hier mit dem Zettel am Horizont
auftaucht du gewöhnst sich an alles
Einsatzbefehle verteilen wir über unsere
private whatsappgruppe Munition bestelle
ich bei Alibaba und weil das meldemopet
auch längst kaputt ist reite ich jetzt
auf meinem klappsparten Richtung
Zapfenstreich
Attacke hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf
Gefällt mir drückt und den Kanal
abonniert zeige ich euch meinen
lautesten Schrei für das menschliche
Gehör ist zwar nicht wahrzunehmen aber
ich würde eure Hunde kurz rausbringen
okay
fertig